we are now live on youtube and i'm
sharing the link with you all
in the chat box so if any one of you
misses out on the network you can watch
the recording later on this link
thank you for joining the webinar we
will be starting in few minutes
and please do write in the chat box
about yourself
what are you studying and also about
your interest in computational biology
and data science
thank you
thank you sonia for sharing about your
interest
and your background
i welcome those who have just joined we
would be starting in few minutes
till then it would be great if you would
let us know about yourself
about your interest in computational
biology and data science
and about your educational background as
well thank you
thank you professor effie we are pleased
to have you with us
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for today's free webinar
which is about a special opportunity to
learn modern biotechnology
and life science techniques using
innovative or mixed logic research based
online training
my name is sunalika ray and i want to
start by introducing our company
vision and team that stands behind the
various resources and training programs
we will go over today
omixlogic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed in collaboration between pine
biotech
and the toba bioinformatics research
center at the university of haifa
the company was started as a result of
technology transfer from the center
which was founded by dr
alfred trauber and dr liunet brotzky
dr alfred tauber who comes from a
medical background has extensive
expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives
that support data science training and
applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
toba bioinformatics resource center
at the university of haifa and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training
some of our team members will be
presenting today as well
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research projects
using our omics logic
program project based curriculum
over the past several years we had the
privilege of working with a number of
organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
using the cutting edge omixlogic
resources we bring a unique opportunity
to learn computational biology and apply
data science techniques by working with
experts bioinformaticians
and in today's webinar we will go
through the introduction to the program
followed by an overview of basics of
bioinformatics and big data
concepts and applications genomic
medicine and sequencing data analysis in
biomedical research
application of microbiome and
metagenomics analysis in life sciences
and transcriptomics data analysis and
its application
in the machine learning before we go
through the topics that will be covered
in the program
as a community manager i interact with
participants who are interested to know
if they are eligible for the training
program
let me explain that so this program is a
great fit for students who are
interested in learning about the ongoing
life science research
and to develop skill sets to analyze
genetic and clinical data
this program is also a great fit for
researchers who are keen to apply
computational biology tools
to their research projects and faculty
while working on the research projects
and proposals and have a keen interest
in the
in teaching bioinformatics the
industry-driven omics logic curriculum
helps
biologists and clinicians working with
industry
and research labs to analyze their own
data
and take decisions based on the analysis
this program is available through our
collaborators and mentors in the us
canada india sri lanka and for the
students and researchers in africa as
well
now to talk more about omixlogic
bioinformatics training and
computational biology program
i would like to invite dr mohit mazumdar
who has a phd in computational biology
from jawaharlal nehru university and is
an author of more than 30 international
publications
on bioinformatics research over to you
dr bennett
thank you sonalika
thank you sonalika for the introduction
hello everyone
we are absolutely delighted to have you
all today for this webinar on
computational biology program for
everyone joining for the first time
um my name is mohit mazumdar and i'm a
bioinformatician by
education and uh since uh last 12 years
i've been practicing
and applying bioinformatics for research
and now
for both research uh training and
collaborations
to all the participants who have joined
us today it would be really nice uh to
know your background educational
background too
and i saw that many of you have already
shared with us so nice to know
um about uh your research interest about
your educational background so that
we can understand and guide you better
so if you are from life science then you
must have studied biotechnology right
so biotechnology has been in use since
1919
so it's a long time back and it has
its first application was in dna
recombination experiment with bacteria
right
and today biotechnology in itself has
been applied in manufacturing of
medicines
medicinal devices diagnostic tools
bio materials food technology and food
production
all of that but today we wanted to talk
to you about another exciting field
which is computational biology so
computational biology
which is a relatively new field of uh
research
has been evolving at an exponential
phase and
it's such an exciting field of biology
and
we will learn more about it in today's
session
and to talk a little bit about uh
computational biology there's a reason
that this
exponential pace that
it has got it is because of the enormous
amount enormous amount of
biological data that has accumulated
over the years
and the size of this data is uh ever
growing
and the application of biology in life
in itself
is growing already and it has been shown
even for the experiment that uh some
scientists did
a few a few days a few months ago that
dna can be used to store
uh data just like our typical hard
drives right
scientists were able to show that 700
terabytes of
uh data could be stored in a single
you know single gram of dna so that's
like pretty exciting right
so but our objective here is to simplify
complex bioinformatics methods that have
been applied in these
amazing experiments and then uh
we want also want to use these methods
effectively and efficiently to tackle
unsolved problems in biology and in
healthcare
so i would also like to tell you about
in much more detail about the omics
logic program
but before i do that i would like to ask
uh
if any one of you would like to have a
discussion a question
please feel free to put it in the chat
chat option
so that we can go through this later and
answer your questions
so going back to the presentation and
about the homicide programs and
what we've been doing and been talking
about so the goal of omislogic program
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer examples
another aspect of uh important aspect of
omics logic program is to develop a
growing community with a shared passion
for data-driven research
and application of citizen scientist
science projects
so we have a growing community of over
10 000 people who are computational
biologists
researchers biologists clinicians
who interact with each other and enrich
this information
sharing and collaboration the third
objective is to enable students
and clinicians and faculty of all
background people who are interested
genuinely
would want to learn more about it apply
these skill sets
in their research areas in for job
opportunities
and to develop noble and independent
research using uh
life science or the latest uh
technologies in
in bioinformatics and computational
biology so these are some of the
objectives that we
that we wanted to tell you all about
and the next thing uh is about the
program itself
because we would want to you know
complete some of these objectives
by going through a training method so
this online program is designed for
everyone including students who don't
have a background in bioinformatics
so the topics covered in this program uh
enables anyone to learn the
ngs data analysis because we will be
going through
different kind of processing sections
but for doing different sort of analysis
such as
genomic analysis and i've heard many of
you are interested in transcriptomic
analysis
and interpreting the omics data using
machine learning techniques
so we will learn about uh also along
with this we will also be learning about
public repositories where various file
formats are being you know deposited
by different laboratories and companies
and their application
and then understanding their application
for biological research
so this analysis will include we will be
doing annotation
visualization and interpretation of the
results
so uh before we go into those technology
um let me start today by mentioning that
uh as a company in this space we are
focused on
addressing some of the pressing needs in
biotechnology
and in clinical market by providing user
friendly tools for researchers
clinician students to leverage this
transformational opportunity of our
lifetimes
because this is where the where the
innovation is coming this is where the
latest technology is heading to us today
we will be learning about the overview
of topics
as uh as promised that will be covered
in the program
so let's start discussing about the
basics of bioinformatics
big data and this concepts and
applications
so in in bioinformatics
um if we talk about big data so the
biological experiments
produce magnitude of multitudes of data
today so compared to 20 years ago so
before that we were using single
experiments to generate data now there
are
thousands of experiments automated
experiments that are generating this
multitude of data and then we have open
source data
databases like ncbi uh scientists from
different part of the world
can share their data and can collaborate
with ease
so that's the new world and we have now
crossed the
excel barrier as well so earlier we were
used to
use i mean most of the time we even use
excel
ms excel for uh for uh you know
collaborating and sharing data so
bioinformatics researchers
who are now are adapt with uh
statistics data and programming on top
of
domain knowledge there are also demands
such as you know
learning tools such as panda nymphy
matplot
r shiny all of that that actually
efficiently help
us to you know maybe use machine
learning as well
so this is uh right now is the
market in bioinformatics and there's a
huge opportunity associated with it
or also because it's a growing market
and uh
it has a lot of demand for
all the biomedical research that is
ongoing disease related research
and many more application that today we
will discuss
so learning about this i mean what is
the gap
where we are i mean what is lacking and
what we can do
so breakthroughs in molecular biology
advances of precision medicine
biotechnology and agriculture have
translated into
advanced technologies right because now
we are generating data
with ease and that simplified generation
of
accurate and in-depth data is
is something like a blessing in a way
but
at the same time it poses like a lot of
uh questions because there's a lack of
analytical
power and appropriate skills that
creates
like a huge gap because we have high
quality data now
but we need experts to understand that
data and make sense of that data
so those expertise and skill sets are
lacking
and many of uh because of this there's
this gap
between data and information in this in
this field of computational biology
and bioinformatics and from a standpoint
of what has been
seen as so bioinformaticians as such
were viewed more like you know computer
scientists before
who could manage a database maybe run
some algorithms but modern
bioinformaticians
are different and i'm telling you i'm
going to tell you why
because modern bioinformaticians have to
identify
what questions what questions a
researcher
should ask how to look for um
right answers that's a very important
part
and then how to what to do with this
large data large amount of data produced
from these studies
that is also a job of a bioinformatician
to learn and understand
and also for all those people who are in
a pa
who are in biology and are now
progressing towards
uh learning more about biology and its
application
so in bioinformatics uh
now um as i was telling you about the
opportunities
these scientists who are being able to
do all of this
who can ask the research question find
data set
understand what answer that data set can
give
these scientists are now integrated into
every research team
making them into the core of innovation
so it's very important uh
and uh these uh so biology
and as a field has been now ushering
with the age of ai
big data with it and creating a new line
of scientists that's where i'm coming at
which is bioinformaticians and
computational biologists
so now about uh bioinformatics
and the different kind of challenges
so when we talk about you know technical
demand that prevents us from learning
these skill sets
because of the computational power that
is sometimes required
for us to do all this analysis so in
most of the cases that
that means that you know our ability to
analyze data
and extract meaningful meaningful
information
is lagging behind because of the pace at
which the new
new data is being generated so often
times like clinician
biologists students from life science
background report about
challenges with data analysis and
interpretation that is holding them back
and limiting their ability to rely on
advanced technologies such as genomes
genomic sequencing
which we could incorporate in our
studies in our research
and that could actually give us a really
bright clear picture of what what is
going on
so uh if i talk about bioinformatics and
uh computational biology
the first three words that you know
wikipedia used to describe
bioinformatics
are um is an it is an interdisciplinary
field
so when we talk think about these three
broad fields
for example biology statistics computer
science
or you can say instead of statistics
data science but
what exactly these disciplines uh are
and
are there other fields within this these
disciplines
so when it comes to application in the
context of biology
the current realm of uh molecular
biology
in the current realm of biology includes
molecular biology
genetics uh genomics proteomics
metabolomics systematic
evolution evolution pharmacology
biomedicine
healthcare healthcare health sciences
and
and the list goes on so this is not an
exist exhaustive list but
when it comes to computer science there
are there are like obvious ones
like uh software engineering database
management
uh information uh information
engineering
natural language processing image
processing so these are
some of the fields that are associated
with the interdisciplinary nature of
bioinformatics or computational biology
and how we can now
being being able to utilize these
different areas
of uh you know these different
technologies into
one area of biology so so what is
bioinformatics i think it's a
convergence of biology and data
where both are equally important
so um we've been talking about data
so let's understand some of the data
types which are like some of the genetic
data types
omix data types so omix data includes
phenomics genomics
[Music]
epigenomics technologies and that can be
used to
these technologies are uh are so
important in today's world because they
can be used to explore the roles
relationships actions of various types
of molecules
that makes up our cell that makes up a
cell of an organism
so many of this omics data can be
generated using the ngs technology which
is
uh commonly also known as high
throughput sequencing
and this data shows as i was telling you
before this data shows detailed
information
about genomic variants pattern of gene
isoform expression and for an entire
organism
and for that entire time point so
the application of this technology these
technologies is something that is really
exciting
and that we will be learning about in
the next few in the next
few slides so one particularly
exciting area of bio bioinformatics is
its use in precision and
personalized medicine i think many of
you have heard about it
so what what is happening is doctors are
learning more and more about the
influences of the gene on a person's
physiology
is a person's metabolism and more
importantly how
drugs uh interact with their exact
phenotypes
so these are some of the things other
than that using per patient's
personal genetic makeup and comparing it
with the database of thousands of other
patients
doctors can make more informed decisions
about treatment
and therapeutic choices so these are
some of the possibilities that are
already happening
in many places some of the drugs may be
more efficient for a patient than others
while some of the drugs may may have
more unwanted side effects
for some other patients all all these
could be
you know theoretically can be evaluated
now
given the hospital haven't i mean maybe
hospital or the organization
have an access to those databases
and then they have the expertise to
compare
and find similar genotypes that could be
treated with similar drugs
so there are different uh applications
in medical sciences
that that could help make the entire
healthcare system or the medical science
more robust empirical and casual than
uh correlational and or uncertain
right so most of such data types are
generated randomly
at a high speed these sort of data sets
are
generated at a really high speed and
these require
like com complex computational data
processing system
a procedure to generate structured data
sets
which can be visualized and analyzed uh
statistically so that is some of the
challenges
that are associated with such high
throughput data
but i mean this is a program that where
we would want to simplify that
and take you through this entire process
of how we can
actually do this by uh
learning the logic
now um this about this training program
so in this first training program we
will have live sessions
uh every week and uh the first live
session will be about
orientation and introduction to omix
logic coursework and access to the
multiomics user friendly tibianfo
platform uh
so after the program registration and
many of you might have already
registered
for the program uh the first week
we will have participants uh and we will
have orientation under introduction
section
uh session in this session we will be
collaboratively working with students
to complete their academic uh profile on
learn omics logic
and set up accounts on big data
analytical tbanford platform
so uh about this i mean anyone
anyone can join the omixologic
bioinformatics community
for free and and that will we will be
showing you
in a while uh so in this week we will
also learn about big data
application of bioinformatics and uh
after we do the sign up which we will be
doing in the next
next few slides i'll be taking you
through the hands-on
courses and the premium courses
associated with
each week for you to learn all of this
on your own
so in the next session uh after the
first orientation
session and the introduction session
where we get to learn
about you about your interest about the
area
that you would want to work on maybe if
not about the basic training
the help that you need to go to the next
level so
in the next session we will be learning
about this various ngs technology
and ngs technologies starting with
genomics we will learn to
we will learn to analyze uh ngs genomic
data
and to give you an overview genomics is
an
uh is an essential essential sub
subfield of bioinformatics
and is a major force in expanding human
knowledge for genetically associated
associations with disease and other
traits it's an interdisciplinary field
again
and it includes development of methods
for dna sequencing
as well as big data analysis for genomic
sequences so ngs data or ngs
techniques allow whole genome sequencing
and then
analysis of epigenetic factors uh for
as epigenomics for dna protein
interaction
dna methylation with i mean it is
very efficient and which has very
efficient
way to identify those and there are
massive databases obviously i talked
about
ncbi there's gene bank embl sra
for uh for you to do data driven
discovery and knowledge discovery
so this session uh serves an as an
introduction
to the field sub disciplinary field of
genomics
participants will get familiarized with
biology of genetics genetic variation
and other practical applications
and to tell you i mean i will be telling
you more about this
uh entire week uh once we go once you
all
are signed up so that we can have a like
a demonstration
of what will be covered so in the next
session after learning about
genomics uh we will learn about
metagenomics or you will have an
opportunity to learn about
metagenomics so uh this is a one month
program
and i would want to clarify that we will
have you will have a
lot of resources that you can you know
complete in that period or you can
extend
uh keep on extending and keep on
learning
about different data types so yeah
obviously
there's an opportunity to do this right
now in a month's time but
i mean many of you would want to go and
deep dive
and keep can do uh these analysis
after subscribing for the program um
every month
so in this session we will learn about
application of microbiome metagenomic
analysis and life sciences
and uh as as you know metagenomics is to
study
a collection of genetic materials or
genomes from a mixed community of
organisms
metagenomics is uh usually refers to
study of microbial community
and we have also
different projects in metagenomics to
explain
different sort of analysis that i'll
take you through after the login
so in after the metagenomics section
we will move to another section of
analysis which is transcriptomics
analysis this is like high throughput
gene expression data analysis
so in this session we will be uh doing
the analysis
using omix logic resources and the tbi
info platform
that we will be talking to you about uh
very soon
in the session so transcriptomics to
give you an overview is
is to study uh organisms transcriptome
the transcriptome refers as a sum of an
organism
uh organisms rna transcript right so
the dna information that is there in the
genome
gets converted into rna through a
process called transcription
a segment of dna that gets transcribed
into uh
into an rna molecule is called the
transcriptome
transcript unit so studying and
understanding the transcriptome
gene expression expression levels help
us
understand that what are the proteins or
what are the
you know key genes that were maybe
expressed differently in a different
condition so it is also about
comparing comparing these uh different
uh expression profiles that we get from
different experiments
and uh that technology and will be
also covered like com doing differential
gene expression
how would you do that how can you uh get
from raw data to a structured table of
expression first of all
and uh identify which are the important
genes that have shown this variation by
using
different type of statistical analysis
so we will be learning
we will be learning and we will also
learn to use this various statistical
methods of data analysis using
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning
that can be applied to biomedical data
or different kind of other data types
so using various examples of omics data
we will see
how such analysis can yield significant
results
for various biomedical applications and
it's i quoted this because it's very
important because
when you are looking uh in for
information from a very big data
it's like finding needle from the
haystack so
significant uh result is something that
is
uh very important and could be you know
if it is a research it could be
publishable as well
so um about the omics logic program
in this omics logic beginners training
program
the participants will have an
opportunity to learn about various
technologies
tools algorithms and pipelines and
workflows and data sets and research
publications
and these are some of the six data types
that you can see on the slide
so together with this existing module
modules
for which you will gain access for the
omixlogic learn portal
where you can explore these modules uh
exercise the pipeline building
how can you build a pipeline how can you
do uh coding from the very basic
and apply it for bioinformatics not
hardcore
programming and various methods of
analysis using project uh
examples from peer reviewed
peer-reviewed publication
but to start with this i mean uh we
will have to do uh the login or the sign
up together
so uh now let me invite uh sunalika
now again our community manager to help
us
create a login show us all how to create
a login
and then we will start exploring these
resources that i just discussed
thank you so much dr mohamed now i would
request you
all to go to our portal that is learn
dot omics logic
i'm sharing the link with you all in the
chat box
it would be great if you could follow
along
now once you are on the portal you need
to login
if you have not created an account yet
then you need to sign
up those who have signed up
already uh please let me know in the
chat box by sending a yes
or one maybe and those who have not yet
signed up
you can go along here is the link for
the for you all
in the chat box and
you have two options to sign up it would
be great if you could create an account
for yourself with your mail id
and create a password as well or you can
also log in with your social account
let me know in the chat box if you are
going along
thank you what about others have you
logged in
let's wait for five minutes maybe or two
to three minutes for you all to log in
please let me know in the chat box i'm
waiting for you all to login
thank you priyanka thank you ruby
thank you sonia
for those who have logged in let me just
tell you how you have to
begin with so to begin with first of all
you have to
update your profile picture and also
link in your social account
and ensure that you have your name in
the correct format
it should be title case and not in
capitals or not in small
because this is the name that would be
reflected on your certificates
yes madhumita i can wait for you
thank you chika
those who have already updated their
profile it's good others can update
their profiles
uh in between the session or later as
well
and you can see all your activity in the
profile tab so let's say you started
with a course on genomics or let's say
bytes and molecules
you can see how many lessons you have
covered
and how many are still to go and once
you have covered or completed all the
sessions you would be
able to get the certificate in the in
the certificates tab
in your profile section itself
and after joining the program on the
omixlogic bioinformatics and
computational biology you would be
able to see the program under your
profile
and as the program has not started yet
that's where it
shows zero out of four so once the
program would begin i would be
posting in all the recordings for the
program on the program page
and you would have to complete the
sessions to get the certificate
on the program page we have mentioned
about what all would be included in the
program
so we have four workshops in total and
dr
mohit would be explaining about each and
every workshop in detail
and i would be uploading the recording
of each and every workshop once it's
over
and also you would be able to find the
schedule for the program
so i had a message in the chat box
where the participant was asking about
the schedule so we have four sessions
scheduled on uh second august fifth
august ninth august and twelfth august
and also you would be guided towards the
asynchronous course material
have you all signed up please let me
know
in the chat box sorry
while others are signing up i would just
want to quickly launch a poll
to know about you all in a more better
way my first question
is what is your educational background
are you an undergraduate graduate post
graduate
phd or a postdoc
and my second question is what is your
current position
are you a student researcher faculty
or are you from management and
administration
and my third question is what are your
research interests
is it infectious diseases genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics
data science machine learning or
bioinformatics using
r or python
the pool would be up for a minute thank
you for
giving out your votes
i can see 40 people uh have
already voted i would request others to
vote as well
uh yoke you have to go to the profile
section and update your profile
after your after you are done with
signing up on the portal
and we will be sharing the program page
link with you all
for you to register
thank you sonalika if i may take over
now yes
over to you sir thank you
i'm ending the poll i hope everyone uh
has voted
over to you dr moment okay thank you
sonalika
and uh if you can see my screen
yes sir we can see your screen
sorry
so let us go to the mix logic learn and
i have logged in
i have a profile here as uh sanatika
showed all of us
that you can create your profile and you
can have a picture
and you can have your name and social
media links if you like
you will see the courses that you
complete and
the achievements that you did though you
will also accumulate points for your
achievements
so i've accumulated almost 5000 points
and i've gained two certificates so far
so you can keep on doing the courses and
gain
a lot of certifications for the courses
itself and the
for program if you're joining the
program you can
also you will also be eligible to get a
program certificate
now uh going back to some of the
questions whether this program is a paid
program
how do you access the resources that we
discussed how to go about the training
and what are the next steps
these are something that i am going to
tell you about in much more detail now
so uh in omix logic community as i said
it's a free community anyone can join
for free here you can see register for
free
but uh there are premium courses which
requires you to utilize the
uh tbanfo server so there's a
subscription for the program
a minimal a very minimal cost that we
have kept together and that's why we are
calling it a special
opportunity for you to learn from us and
learn from
the resources that are available so you
can join
the program to access the premium
courses
otherwise you will have access to the
free courses i will tell you which free
courses and
how you can access those as well once
you have created a login i'll do that
but before that i mean if you are
interested in going through the entire
you know sessions going through the
workshops by experts
uh going through the premium courses and
all of that then you
have to join the program uh through this
page
and it's kind of simple so let me
show you i'm already a part of the
program
so if i have to join the program how can
i join you obviously you'll have to
log in from your account first and then
you will see the program page and once
you go in this program page
or if you can also like go to the link
directly you will be able to come to
this program page
and then you will have to complete your
registration
so you can give your information and you
we will be sending you more information
about the program
more details if you are not sure about
what will be covered and at the same
time you can start your application and
you book your seat
so it's a program that will be available
for anyone to take
and you can join this entire whatever we
covered in today's session will be
available with a beginner's license so
we have different subscription levels
so the first beginner subscription level
is just for ten dollars a month which
will give you access to all of the
things that we discussed today and
we have different other subscription
levels for you to do research
for you to do work on project and uh
maybe we will discuss it in the next
time when we meet
but for this program you will be able to
do all the course work and all the live
sessions that we just
discussed and about the coursework i'm
going to tell you
what all coursework are there which are
for free and which are for premium and
why they're premium
and why there's a cost so let me go back
to the slide deck
yeah the first course that we have put
together for everyone to take
is a free course uh other than the ones
that you've seen star or the premium
ones
so uh when you do this course and go
through this course bytes and molecule
you get an
overview of a very basic understanding
about the different data types that we
will be discussing
in the program so anyone coming from a
background
without a knowledge of biology can start
taking this
course bytes and molecules so let me
just quickly show you a video
for the same
bytes and molecules
every living cell has its own hard drive
where it stores
bytes of information needed to function
and grow adapt to environmental changes
and fight off dangerous intruders this
information is stored in molecules that
are
arranged in sequences of letters
referred to as dna code
in the 1990s a tremendous effort by
governments
researchers and companies resulted in
the full sequence of the human genome
since then we've seen an exponential
growth of molecular data that describes
cells
tissue organs and organisms massive data
sets containing genetic information
about the young
old healthy and sick are now freely
available to the public
here we will explore the various omics
data types as well as examples of the
information they contain
genomic variants associated with
ancestry gene
expression levels responsible for cancer
spread and
protein modifications that can render
important code
unreadable this course is intended for
all those interested in
understanding how the current revolution
in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health
so as you learn from this this is the
first course that you will go through
uh and this is a free course anyone can
take and
in this course you will learn about the
different data types
another free course that we have is the
introduction to bioinformatics
uh it's a course that takes you through
different types of
you know application of bioinformatics
big data bioinformatics as i said
and it's a course where we get to learn
about you your
expectations what do you want to learn
in bioinformatics which area
of research that you are interested in
so this course has a form when you start
this taking this course
uh you will get a form and i'll request
to sonalika to share maybe the
link to this course as well so this is
an introductory course
where you will get the overview of
different type of
fields where you can apply
bioinformatics and you can also tell us
about
your area of research where you are
interested in
so these two courses is something that
you
we would want you to start with uh even
if you are joining the program even if
you're not
not joining the program it will be
really helpful for you to go through
these courses
so once you go through these courses uh
we
also have other free courses
introductory courses for r for omics
bioinformatics as i said
that in this program you will also have
opportunity to learn coding
you will have also have an opportunity
to
learn uh this from the browser itself
and get points and recognition and all
of that
by while completing this coursework so
in the
this first tutorial which is just to get
started with bioinformatics
it tells you about you know loading
structural data into our
a multi-dimensional data visualization
in our
readings a very uh basic uh file
uh dna file and then understanding the
dna replication and reverse complement
complements in r so this is a
here also you will have free courses
where you can learn about these
different technologies and how it can be
applied different programming languages
how it can be applied for data
visualization now i mean i told you
about the premium courses
as well so the premium courses how they
can help you
do the hands-on analysis on on yourself
by yourself at your
own pace so let's take a look at that
let's have a demonstration about that as
well
so let's go to the learn portal again
and uh
now what we will do is that we will go
to the section called courses
and we will find all the courses that we
are interested in
if you are interested in python we can
try python if you are interested in r
we can do r if you are learning one want
to learn about the introduction to
bioinformatics and genomics
and then epigenomics then all of this
course material
is here we will just have to search for
them
and and i'll show you that's
pretty simple
okay i'll have to login first
so i'm logged in now i can see the
courses
so let's take a look at the our course
so we have different courses as i said
getting started with our
another course is introduction to data
science
using our now we have a lot of
lessons within these courses that you
can take
and earn points from so let me show you
how it works
and how it is so simple and easy to do
this that anyone can learn from this
because when you start from you know
basic
you tend to get an understanding of
what's going on and you understand
different type of
app different type of commands that are
being used and get familiarized with
it so we start with uh you know you can
install
r locally on your computer as well and
try this out and you can do this
from the browser itself as well so
with every tutorial that you see here
the first part is the
about is to understand the problem what
the problem is all about
what we are doing here so we are doing
we are looking at different type of
data categorical data or continuous data
in data science and then
we are trying to do some plotting to see
the characteristics of data
i mean how they are placed if we can you
know separate them or not
so this is being used in many of the
bioinformatics application in many
bioinformatics application
especially when we are doing big data
analysis so here i mean you will learn
to
upload the data how you can use links
and uh
upload that data into the into the
in into the browser and then you can run
different sort of
commands to analyze that data so once we
learn about these different commands
which is just shown here you can go
through them
and easily learn about them then there
is a breakdown of code that will be used
for this tutorial
so what this code is doing so it
actually explains all of it and what
kind of
results that we can expect and what kind
of uh
analysis that we can do from this sort
of data
so once you do this uh you get to a
point that
where you can practice it yourself so
it's a
code playground where you can write your
own code and you can load data and you
can run the analysis here itself
to show that if if you're getting the
result or not as you see
as as you like as you can see that this
is already a
code that is put together and it's
working you can change this
and you can uh run your own code and do
your own analysis downstream analysis
using this code
uh code blocks uh and different
tutorials that have been shown here
uh that has been shown here in the
learn portal that you will have access
to so
uh the opportunity is there is a lot of
opportunity to learn about different
things
so i just told you about uh this r code
now let me go back to the uh to the
slides
and i'll show you what all different
courses that we have put together for
you to take so uh you can start from
python as well similar courses
you can apply and see what is the
difference how you can learn
both of them and i mean choose what you
are
i mean more comfortable in and what kind
of analysis that you are
into and what kind of research that
requires to
use these languages and apply these
languages for data analysis
so another thing another important
aspect of
this uh this sort of learning omics
logic bioinformatics training
is to be able to access the tbi info
platform
and run your own analysis and get the
structured data to analyze further in
r and python so when we go through
uh these courses such as genomics
as i said in the second session after
the introduction session we will be
doing
genomics so in genomics we will be going
through
very basic starts from the dna structure
and variants why we are
using the genomic technology genomics
technology
and where it has been helpful how we can
identify variants
and identify mutations that are critical
so uh learning about that working using
art then introduction to genomics
where you get an overview of all of that
in much more detail in depth
and then practicing using the pipelines
as i was telling you that
you will be getting an overview and
understanding of
how by how algorithms are connected
together
and they give us a result
a structured result after doing a
complete analysis
so there are several tutorials and the
ones that are starred
uh includes practical uh assignments
so for that you will be able to access
the t by info server
to uh to run some example pipelines and
now let me take you to the tbi info
server
and show you how it works and why it is
so easy for anyone to use
i mean even students ban without a
background in bioinformatics
and computational i mean in
computational sciences can do this so
this is the tibia info server
and once you register we will be sharing
uh
the access for you to take some of the
example pipelines from here
and now let me show you an example
pipeline from the transcriptomics data
analysis
so it's an ai guided uh platform and we
have put together
examples from publications that you can
take and learn from and
at the same time you learn about the
logic so many of these algorithms that
you see here
are open source algorithms so our
purpose is not to
make you dependent on a platform for
data analysis but
make it simple so that you understand
how the algorithms are used
what are the outcome what are the
outputs that you get from this sort of
analysis
and how to interpret that result so
understand the logic
behind the analysis is what we are
focused on that's why we are called umix
logic
and uh to do this i mean we have put
together many examples for you to go
through
one of the examples that i'm taking you
through is the cell line data set
so it's a rna-seq experiment where uh
the scientists
or the researchers have uh generated
data
on cell line using cell line breast
cancer cell line
samples and then we are processing the
raw data here
using these pipelines so we have already
put together
different sections for different sort of
analysis for example
pre-processing mapping quantification
these are different
sections that you have to go through to
process data and get a structured table
and now one thing that you can see is
that they are differently colored
so to make it more easy and simple they
are color coded so that you understand
that
these sections are used for
pre-processing these sections are used
for mapping
this is for quantification of expression
level and what are all of these steps
and we will be going through in detail
in other in the workshop session
and also they are described i mean
absolutely amazingly in the courses
that you will have access and you will
have go through you'll have
the opportunity to go through in this
training so
the input file and the output files are
already stored because the example
pipeline for you to learn
so the first step that we do in such
analysis is to
clean the data make it more structured
so we use
uh algorithms such as dramatic pcr clean
and then i'm going to show you how we
can map it to the transcriptome
and then generate a table of expression
so if you can see i i should be little
slow i know
but uh it's a quick demonstration and
we'll be going through this
in much more detail in the session and
it's described in the courses as well
but here also you will be able to learn
about these
these pipelines these algorithms what
they do
what paper that you can read about them
also
and learn about them in much more detail
uh so here uh what we did
is that we preprocessed the data we
mapped it to a
transcript term and we when we say if we
are mapping or aligning it to a
transcript term
we are doing it on a reference
transcript term and then we are
generating a table of expression after
doing the
uh alignment or the comparison and then
we are doing ending the pipeline
and here you will see that there are
different courses that you can take
and go through which are on the learn
portal
now uh during the session we will be
able to tell you the
output and how to exp how to uh you know
analyze these uh
results and what is the outcome and what
can you do next
so the next step is to take this data
structure table run some uh other
analysis
and do some machine learning analysis
based on the research
that we are looking going through so
this is the way we
uh kind of go and explore the tiva info
platform
and obviously it has also the capability
to
to do the analysis right from ncbi so
you can upload data from ncbi
you can upload data from your own
research lab and those
are available with different
subscription options
to access this platform with the program
you will be able to use it for
educational purpose you can be
you'll be able to do example pipelines
and learn first
before you do your own experiments so
that's the process that we follow
for you to go through the technology uh
first
go through the steps uh do the data
analysis on example projects
and then learn on your own or public
data that is available
and that we discussed that it's so huge
that we have been able to do
a lot of quality research out of that
data so this is about the tbi info
platform that you will have access to
and this is this is the coursework for
genomics and then we have the coursework
for
metagenomics it's very elaborated
coursework as
as i was telling you there are examples
here that you can learn from
and learn about the otus learn about
different types of metagenomic analysis
learn about the data to pipeline file
seek all of this is compare
is covered in different uh tutorials
under this section so if you go to the
course for metagenomics you will find
all of them bundled together that you
can take one by one
and learn about and apply this to your
own research once you've been able to
do go through this material which is
mostly hands-on
and also gives an overview of all the
technology and there are also videos in
the tutorials
so you will be able to go through the
videos uh recorded videos
and uh replicate that using the t-band
for platform
because at the same time you will have
an access to do this hands-on thing
so that's why the zomex logic training
is a really unique opportunity
to learn for real so the next uh
technology that we will be covering is
the transcriptomics technology
and we have detailed explanation of this
transcript of
transcriptomics data analysis we've been
doing several programs
and have a lot of participants who have
gone through this
training and come up with a unique
projects that have been published
as well as uh got recognition in various
conferences and
presentations so another aspect of doing
an advanced level analysis is to learn
about
uh the application of machine learning
and
we use different type of machine
learning regression
uh so their effect factor regression
analysis supervised machine learning
unsupervised machine learning uh to kind
of
get insights and results from
transcriptomics data analysis
another advanced section that is again
available
i mean as i said it's a
subscription-based model if you are
into this then you can go in deep into
this and maybe
you know try different courses run some
ideas that
share with us some research ideas that
we can work on so there are different
ways we can collaborate and do research
together
so singles and transcriptomics is such a
area very promising area
a lot of modern research and high
value research is coming out of high
impact research is coming out of single
cell analysis
and there's a lot of data that has been
deposited as well
so uh another uh aspect of doing this
all of this
is to learn machine learning how we can
apply machine learning by ml
that that is also is in there in the
course work
so you will also have opportunity i know
that there is a lot of course work that
you can do and learn from
so you can also take your time and go
through this analysis at your own pace
and at the same time done from the video
that will be recorded and provided to
you
and we will have also mentors that you
can you know connect with
and learn about specific sort of
analysis
all those opportunities uh are available
on with us for this omixlogic training
so that is about the coursework that is
there
uh other than that i have already told
you about the data science part
uh for r and python and then we have
mentors that and then we have programs
and which uh which which i can show you
actually quickly here on the website uh
so
when when you're logged in you have
option to do coursework
you have option to select a program and
you have option to do research
so we believe that it's best to start
with the coursework go through the
examples
and then conduct your own research and
learn from specialization programs one
of such program is this one
that is omix logic bioinformatics and
computational biology
people interested in infectious diseases
data science transcriptomics
we have specialization programs that we
keep on doing
as well for those but to those who are
just started this is a best opportunity
for you to take
omislogic bioinformatics and
computational biology
so that was about my presentation and i
hope that
you were able to understand what i have
covered
and what we have covered and talked
today and
if there are any questions i'll be happy
to take those questions
and at the same time it would be
great for you to ask them right now
and then i would like to maybe
invite uh our ceo ilia brodsky
to tell you a little bit more about
research and the opportunities
uh with research that we have we have a
symposium coming up
uh in on august 21st and 22nd where we
will be showcasing all of this research
that our
interns are doing and then there will be
opportunities to
uh you know talk uh talk about your own
research as well
so over to you yeah
yes thank you very much mohit and uh
welcome everyone
great to see all of you here i will just
briefly introduce the symposium
just kind of starting off with why this
is the right time so
as mohita has already mentioned there
have been numerous breakthroughs in
molecular biology
including advances of precision medicine
biotechnology agriculture
all of these have translated into
advanced technologies that actually
simplify generation of accurate and
in-depth data
but the lack of analytical power and
appropriate skills
creates a huge gap between data
and the bioinformatic and the
information that is needed
in many of these fields so there's
actually a gap
between the lab and people who make
decisions and so to
bridge this gap we started looking into
some information from
people who are involved in this kind of
uh in these kinds of tasks and
the survey clearly shows that the
majority
of users that are attempting to run
pipelines and analyze
large-scale high-throughput onyx data
are
struggling with the data analysis
component
and so we understood that there has to
be a solution
that is designed for early on
while there are students in high schools
colleges and universities
to actually supplement their educational
curriculum that they already have
introducing them to these challenges
early on
and building a pipeline for them to
develop research skills and practices
in applying their in applying
bioinformatics analysis tools to
large-scale
data sets and actually developing
research projects to showcase what they
have learned so
not a skill based and a certificate
based course but
a research experience and so to
introduce how
this could be done and discuss some of
the challenges that
exist in this field of bioinformatics
and data science for life science data
we are going to hold this omics research
symposium
which is going to be dedicated to the
future of bioinformatics education
and will cover critical challenges and
we hope to identify solutions
for improved educational strategies that
are focused on biology
as a data science and we have a great
panel of
speakers that are experts who will be
addressing the
pressing challenges with data science
education for all life sciences students
and explore how to best equip all life
science students in data skills for the
21st century
our speakers will bring their
perspective as researchers working on
cutting-edge topics in bioinformatics
they're directors of successful degree
programs
and who are seeing their students
continue with successful careers in
education
academic research and industry and
together they will kind of provide us
with a comprehensive view of both the
opportunities for students
and the challenges to be addressed and
hopefully make the most out of their
studies and focus on acquiring the
skills that matter
and that will really help them become
successful and make a true difference in
these emerging fields of biotechnology
precision medicine
bioinformatics data science and others
so
what we will discuss in the symposium is
number one
for students how do you stand out from
the crowd when you apply for academic
programs or careers in bioinformatics
number two for universities how can
universities
equip their students with relevant
skills and experiences
providing them with an opportunity to
stand out
and then we will also discuss the future
of this field of bioinformatics as a
whole
how it's changing it's changed
dramatically over the past 10 years
at least and where we can find these
cutting edge
challenges that someone can contribute
to and these include
you know you can probably think of them
yourself crispr
technologies right revolutionize genomic
engineering
we have genomic sequencing that is under
one thousand dollars for the
whole genome so the sequencing
technologies have been
changed dramatically uh we can also see
the application of machine learning and
ai
deepfold recently released right so we
all hear about that
and obviously mrna vaccines so the
translation from
research to application has been
tremendously sped up already
drug discovery drug repurposing all of
these challenges
have been undergoing a dramatic change
and so
to participate in this revolution
utilizing data science
what our uh interest and our goal is is
to identify
effective practices that allow
students to participate in these
challenges and the way that they can do
it is by learning first about the
challenges
understanding the tools just like you
are listening today to this program
and then applying them and applying them
means developing
research projects and so here we will
also showcase
student projects that have been
completed over this summer
in the past several months we have
hundreds of students working on these
kinds of research projects and
through the same portal that you've
already registered in you will be able
to see
how this happens those will be
evaluated by our team of mentors and
judges
with expertise in bioinformatics
medicine
microbiology biotechnology and others
we will also highlight some of the
exciting updates
to the t bioinfo platform the platform
covers many different types of
bioinformatics applications
but also includes some new sections that
are going to be presented
by the team at the talbot bioinformatics
research center and those
include technologies for single cell
genomics
and multiomics integration advanced
mathematical modeling for different
processes related to the field of
virology
ultra deep sequencing technologies and
the integration of multi-omics data
we will also share some exciting updates
about the omixlogic training modules for
biology as a data science
and we will discuss some of the regional
collaborations that we have in the
united states
india and africa highlighting important
modules that could be applied
to oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture
we will introduce new modules and
project examples from precision medicine
as a preclinical and clinical training
option we will discuss how this pandemic
gave public awareness about infectious
diseases
and what kinds of hands-on exercises
students can access to
to learn about the viral bacterial and
parasite-caused infections
using largely available public domain
data
we will discuss advances in agriculture
and the rise of technology-driven
precision agro-technology with a focus
on sustainable food supply
climate resistant strain reading and
methods of bioinformatics analysis that
are in high demand
in this industry and what areas of
research are
in pressing needs finally we will
introduce
our new and planned specializations like
the field of astrobiology
that is captivating the minds of
students who are seeing the commercial
space industry
take off and develop before their eyes
so together with our existing modules
for which you will gain
access so you already have registered
and you will have access to the basic
modules
you will explore them including all the
different exercises that have been
already mentioned
so importantly what we will
offer for students who are joining is
also some exciting opportunities
to join academic programs so if you are
considering
education and bioinformatics formal
education and bioinformatics
there are many different universities
that offer such programs but
they're not the same in every single
program so
every program has a perspective and a
focus
and a special kind of you know variation
to
the curriculum and the objectives and so
we will bring directors of these
programs to share
how their program is different and what
is the program
kind of focused on and specialized in
and how a student can join and we will
have presenters from carnegie mellon
university
louisiana state university health
sciences center
in new orleans georgetown university
systems medicine program
amity university university of ghana and
others
and the objective here is really to
offer
opportunities for students who are
entering this field or who are
already in this field from data
generation
from bioinformatics analysis and
integration and
all the way to decision making to really
provide them with a comprehensive
bioinformatics training in biology as a
data science so
you can register for free just to attend
if someone could please post the link in
the chat box on how to register
if you uh register and you have
a project that you would like to present
to our judges and evaluators uh
you can also submit a poster
and that poster could be either just
presented
or it could be showcased if it wins a
prize
we have cash prizes that
best posters will receive
in the different categories that we have
and importantly you will get recognition
from many different respected
universities and research centers
that are going to be there and
represented
we will also have companies those
companies will be talking a little bit
about
how they are providing opportunities for
people who are starting their careers
students and recent graduates to get
into internships
and various opportunities to start their
career with
biotechnology utilizing bioinformatics
and data science
so i'm excited about this again this is
august
21 to 22. thank you mohit for sharing
the link
so the link is in the chat you will see
here
that you can simply submit this form to
participate
and learn a little bit more about the
different people who are involved what
are the different topics you can submit
your
research poster if you're interested and
also
look a little bit into what else we are
going to be doing and
here at the bottom you will find a video
presentation and of course
we are all excited to join this and not
only to learn about these
pressing challenges but we also want to
uh
get to know all of you the community
that we interact with regularly
to learn more about what you are doing
and we also have some
hiring ongoing so we're hiring students
and researchers as well so we are
looking to connect with you
uh there as well thank you everyone
that's all i had to share so back over
to you
thank you india i think if there are any
questions
we can answer those and then we can
conclude the sessions
maybe we could just also mention our
social media groups where people can
join and
we can learn about them more there as
well
yes so let me quickly share that
with you
thank you senator for posting the
channel link
so you can join our uh linkedin channels
where we keep on posting about the job
opportunities
and you can also learn about what is
the research which is going on and what
are the programs that we are doing and
the events that we keep on
posting about in you by joining these
groups
you can also join us on facebook uh
using
the link here one second please
subscribe you can also share this
facebook
link
sure sir i would be doing that uh just
in a second
so being a part of our linkedin group
will also help you
get in touch with a lot of researchers
and know about what's going on around
and also stay updated with all our
programs and
courses i'm sharing the link to our
facebook page
and also we have a telegram group and
whatsapp group so that you can stay in
touch with us and also a slack channel
to for better communication i can share
the links as well
and also uh if you have any queries
regarding the program i would be sharing
the
program uh registration link once again
with you all
and if you have any queries you can mail
me at marketing at the
pine dot bio
let me just quickly put it in the chat
box
it's marketing at the pine dot bio you
can also reach out doctor mohit that
movement added fine dot bio and we would
be happy
to clear your queries
so uh sonia and we would be sharing one
more link with you
and also i'm sharing with my number with
you so that i can connect you to the
group
please drop a text on my number
thank you sonia i hope we have no
queries if we have please let us know
and just to clear uh being a part of the
program you would be getting the access
to the
courses and not the programs for one
month
to get the access to the programs you
can visit our program
page and also we have scholarships for
enrollments in the program i have shared
the scholarship
form i will do that once again once you
submit your scholarship application
we'll review it and get back to you with
the best possible scholarship for you
thank you navi for sharing the facebook
group and oh jaspee has shared the
whatsapp group link
sonya you can join this group and
this group is not full yet we have space
thank you everyone for joining this
session uh sridhar is asking please tell
a simple basic bioinformatics book for
beginners
so the book which i would definitely
recommend is zing zion it's a very basic
book and you will get
uh all your doubts cleared from there i
hope that works for you i'll just
name the book
thank you everyone for being a part of
the webinar today
and if you wish to register yourself i
am sharing
the program page link once again and if
you
uh face any of the issues you can
directly contact us
and also uh those who are in india and
you are facing issues to pay
via the program page you can mail me at
marketingpine.bio and we
have alternate options for you for
making the payment and being a part of
the program
please find the program page link in the
chat box thank you for joining we would
be looking forward to meeting you all
on 30th of july on our first session
thank you